el presidente del Consejo Nacional
electoral Pedro calzadilla no especificó
los motivos por los cuales decidieron
poner su cargo a la orden sin embargo
advirtieron que esto era en pro de la
paz del país y de garantizar la
estabilidad política y social de
Venezuela de Cara a unos comicios
presidenciales previstos para el año
2024 importante destacar que los dos
rectores que no están identificados con
el oficialismo Roberto picón y Enrique
Márquez no renunciaron a sus cargos aún
así la asamblea nacional de mayoría
oficialista anunció este jueves que
iniciaría el proceso para la renovación
de todas las autoridades del poder
electoral analistas coinciden en que
esta podría ser una estrategia de la
administración de Nicolás maduro para
perjudicar los comicios primarios de la
oposición previstos para octubre de este
año luego que se conociera que iban a
pedir asesoría técnica al consejo
nacional electoral para su realización y
también una forma de desmotivar el voto
crear mayor desconfianza en el ente
electoral y fracturar aún más a la
oposición venezolana recordemos que el
actual consejo nacional electoral había
sido designado en mayo de 2021 en medio
un proceso de diálogo político entre la
oposición y el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro que buscaba garantías para una
salida electoral a la crisis política
que atraviesa el país